il est fait il est 7h il est
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce sujet pour
le meilleur et pour le sport de avec les
yeux de Morgan alors peut-être êtes-vous
un sportif régulier ou un sportif du
dimanche certains eux font du sport du
lundi au dimanche et emmène le sport
encore plus loin alors qui sont ces
sportifs et jusqu'où emmènent-ils le
sujet du sport la réponse pendant cet
épisode
[Musique]
tout de suite le reportage de TV7 fit et
on retrouve les invités en plateau juste
après
moi tu sais où je peux avoir une sangle
ouais 135 malgré son handicap rien est
impossible pour Ben Kader ce plaisir roi
de 26 ans fait de l'équitation depuis
deux ans aux écuries du château
déficient visuel à 80%, le jeune homme a
dû renoncer à son métier de militaire
dans la cavalerie venir au centre
équestre lui permet de se ressourcer
lorsque je suis à cheval je me base pas
du tout sur sur ma vue mais vraiment sur
mon ressenti et ça me permet d'oublier
en quelque sorte mon handicap dans le
sens où ça me permet de m'évader le
cavalier brosse cure les pieds et
applique des soins à son cheval nommé
exotique de manière autonome ces moments
permettent de gagner la confiance de
l'animal qu'il côtoie depuis quelques
semaines seulement ça lui fait du bien
donc j'en profite et c'est un moment
détente qu'on partage tous les deux
donc il se fait beau je le fais beau mon
but en tout cas c'est d'avoir une
équitation une équitation classique
comme comme une personne voyante et
évoluer comme une personne voyante et
être autonome à 100% je le dis je serai
pas possible mais un maximum d'autonomie
une fois sur la selle direction la
carrière pendant ses entraînements ben
Kader travaille sur les différentes
allures du cheval et pratiquent les
sauts d'obstacles son instructeur Raoul
vient l'assister grâce à des boîtiers
appelés si coach un système permettant
aux deux hommes de communiquer à
distance le plus à droite et maintenant
pression de jambes à droite à droite à
droite en équilibre
là tu étais complètement en biais je me
suis rendu compte que sa progression en
fait elle allait beaucoup plus vite que
sur un cavalier normal parce qu'on
équitation la vue est un ennemi au début
parce que les yeux prennent le relais
sur la les parties du corps qui sont
censées en fin de compte fonctionner par
sensation je pense que depuis qu'on a
commencé à travailler ensemble avec ben
je crois que le moins le moins possible
ça a été complètement banni de notre
vocabulaire ben Kader compte poursuivre
le développement de ces techniques
séquestres si son niveau le permet il
envisage même de participer ces
prochaines années à des concours
hippiques
[Musique]
Eric et Clémence bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être présent pour ce sujet pour le
meilleur et pour le sport je commence
tout de suite
Eric vous vous êtes porteur de projets
sportifs c'est comme ça qu'on peut dire
c'est ça oui c'est ça très bien on va y
revenir juste après et on parlera des
projets à vélo surtout
et Clémence cette fois tu es escrimeuse
handisport ou pareil scrimeuse ça te va
je dis les deux j'ai tout balancé d'un
coup donc avec vous on va pouvoir parler
un peu plus du sport de haut niveau ou
du sport quand on s'implique vraiment
beaucoup dans cette dynamique alors pour
commencer toi Clémence puisque tu
pratiques l'escrime vraiment à haut
niveau comment tu en es arrivé là
comment on en arrive à faire du sport de
haut niveau alors on va l'escrime c'est
arrivé un peu par hasard parce que à la
base je faisais d'athlétisme j'en avais
fait quatre ans et en arrivant sur Paris
je voulais continuer sauf que on m'a mis
dans une catégorie qui correspondait pas
à celle dans laquelle je devais être et
donc comme c'était un peu loin et
c'était pour pas beaucoup de temps j'ai
arrêté et à la suite du coup j'ai
rencontré
l'escrime vraiment par hasard au détour
d'un rendez-vous et j'ai tout de suite
bien aimé après avoir testé donc je me
suis dit pourquoi pas continuer et peu
de temps après on m'a proposé de faire
des compétitions donc moi je partais
plutôt sur une base pour faire du loisir
pour continuer tranquillement et donc je
me suis lancée dans une première
compétition puis après ça s'est vite
enchaîné et donc voilà et donc coup de
foudre pour l'escrime c'est ça
exactement très bien et
Eric est-ce que c'est un peu la même
façon de faire est-ce que c'est un coup
de foudre ou est-ce que vous étiez déjà
un adepte du sport avant
il y a deux ans je ne faisais aucun
sport et suite à une évolution par
rapport à la ma maladie j'ai décidé de
prendre en main et de bousculer un peu
les choses et dans l'optique de me dire
je veux bien avoir mal mais parce que
j'aurais décidé donc en faisant du sport
je fais au delà des limites et donc je
me suis dit que je voulais me lancer des
défis et le défi que je me suis lancé
c'est donc été un premier voyage l'année
dernière en vélo
plus de 500 km jusqu'en Bretagne
d'accord plus de 500 km tout de suite
pour bien commencer pour préparer le
défi que je viens de terminer là au mois
de septembre qui était donc de 1300 qui
1340 km pardon jusqu'à Hendaye
et quand on se lance dans ce type de
défi donc si je comprends bien il y a
pas forcément besoin d'avoir fait du
sport toute sa vie et on peut aussi y
aller à la motivation alors dans mon cas
c'est le cas voilà c'est vraiment ça
c'est alors je me suis entraîné un tout
petit peu mais effectivement j'ai fait
un gros travail psychologique et un gros
travail sur le mental pour dépasser mes
limites et je pense que c'est ce qui m'a
permis de faire ces 1340 km c'est
surtout le mental surtout le mental et
pas forcément tant de préparation
physique que ça pas tant que ça pas dans
les pas dans les conditions dans
lesquelles j'ai pu rouler réellement sur
un instant pendant mon projet je m'étais
entraîné un tout petit peu en vélo
d'appartement mais ça n'a rien à voir
sur le sur la route bien sûr mais voilà
c'est vraiment le mental qui a qui m'a
permis d'avancer
et donc clémence pour la préparation
aussi c'est vrai je rebondis alors il y
a le mental qui joue un grand rôle et
toi alors comment tu te prépares
qu'est-ce qui est le plus important pour
toi dans la préparation voilà
raconte-nous un petit peu comment ça se
passe typiquement je sais pas un duel
d'escrime toute l'organisation donc on
est face à notre adversaire alors en
handisport ça se ça se pratique en
fauteuil donc on est assis le fauteuil
ne bouge pas c'est nous qui bougeons sur
le fauteuil c'est pour ça qu'en amont on
fait pas mal de préparations physiques
pour tout ce qui va être mobilisation de
la chaîne abdominale de l'épaule du bras
parce que c'est vrai que on est on bouge
énormément c'est comme ça qu'on crée la
distance lors de nos assauts et donc du
coup c'est lorsqu'on s'entraîne avant de
préparer une une compétition c'est donc
qu'on fait des entraînements ou on est
en simulation de compétition et aussi on
fait ce qu'on appelle la leçon c'est
face à un maître d'armes où on révise
des zestes techniques ou justement on
est en train de d'apprendre de nouvelles
choses
et oui ça doit jouer un grand rôle
puisque j'ai du mal à me représenter
mais effectivement à la fois tu dis
voilà le fauteuil ne bouge pas mais donc
ça doit demander énormément de réflexes
et oui c'est ça de réflexe de pratique
d'anticipation en fait pour arriver à
échanger se protéger des assauts c'est
ça exactement d'accord on se représente
pas toujours mais oui c'est technique
quand même
tout à fait et
Eric sur les aspects qu'on imagine
peut-être pas dans les Road tripes à
vélo qu'est-ce que vous pourriez nous
communiquer ça se passe comment sur les
routes alors dans mon cas j'avais fait
un itinéraire principalement sur des
pistes aménagées
on a la chance en France d'avoir de plus
en plus de pistes donc voilà j'ai roulé
sur 80% de mon trajet sur des pistes
aménagées
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait s'imaginer les
rencontres voilà il y a tout ça qui
on va dire la partie sportive est une
chose mais c'est tout ce que j'ai pu
rencontrer la bienveillance tout au long
de ce périple je faisais intervention
dans des milieux scolaires et ça a été
très très enrichissant et il m'est
arrivé plein plein de choses j'ai
rencontré des gens incroyables et c'est
vrai que ce principe de road trip en
vélo ça apporte beaucoup de choses
humainement
le retour a été plus difficile on va
dire sur cet aspect là que sur l'aspect
sportif en fin de compte voilà mais
c'est intéressant oui on comprend que
au-delà des kilomètres il y a des étapes
et des moments clés mais ça me permet
justement parce qu'il y a peut-être
plein d'autres choses derrière mais vous
avez pas parlé de la sensibilité enfin
vous venez pardon de parler de la
sensibilisation ça me permet de vous
demander le fait de prendre la route
comme ça à vélo
qu'est-ce que ça peut ouvrir comme porte
qu'est-ce que ça permet aussi derrière
alors dans mon cas vu que je n'ai pas de
force dans les jambes donc pour appuyer
sur le V sur les pédales pour pouvoir
avancer j'ai un vélo sans assistance
donc à chaque intervention dans les
établissements c'est vrai que le fait
d'arriver avec un vélo très chargé les
gens s'ouvrent tout de suite plus
facilement
son très attentifs et le fait de pouvoir
leur montrer réellement mieux va y
arriver
et les gens sont très curieux et sont
très sensibles au final je me suis
aperçu que il y avait vraiment beaucoup
de bienveillance même chez d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus chez les jeunes voilà les
dans les écoles j'ai eu des très bons
retours
donc voilà ça devrait vraiment les
intriguer oui je veux bien croire oui et
Clémence
même question pour toi quand tu
pratiques l'escrime puisque tu as de
l'entraînement des déplacements des
événements qu'est-ce que ça peut
permettre d'autres à part déjà pratiquer
les screams au niveau mais qu'est-ce que
ça peut permettre et comment tu portes
un petit peu toutes les valeurs qui vont
avec je pense être dans le handisport ça
permet déjà ça m'a permis un peu mieux
d'accepter le handicap parce qu'on est
entouré de personnes justement qui ce
qui connaissent l'univers du handicap
qui savent nous conseiller mais aussi
échanger et de voir qu'on connaît pas
tout seul et qu'il y a du monde à notre
écoute et après par rapport à l'escrime
lorsqu'on part à l'international c'est
aussi représenter les couleurs de la
France donc c'est une chouette
expérience de rencontrer de rencontres
pas mal de monde et donc c'est ça c'est
ça qui est sympa
oui c'est vrai qu'il y a la
responsabilité aussi quelque part mais
très motivante c'est ça de représenter
son pays c'est ça aussi voilà c'est ça
puis ça nous donne des objectifs à
chaque fois et puis c'est une autre
façon je trouve de voir le sport de
voilà de passer du loisir à la
compétition ça change de vision mais
c'est tout aussi intéressant d'accord et
motivant oui c'est vrai que tu alors tu
as des rencontres dans plusieurs lieux
peut-être d'ailleurs un petit mot quels
sont les derniers événements les
dernières compétitions sur lesquelles tu
es allé où les prochaines comme tu veux
d'accord alors la dernière compétition
que nous avons faite c'était une coupe
du monde en Italie c'était il y a deux
semaines à peu près et là la semaine
prochaine je pars pour les championnats
du monde junior à Sao Paulo d'accord
rien que ça c'est ça voilà j'aime bien
c'est qu'on est quand même parti au
début de cet échange dans Pourquoi Pas
oui mais le sport de haut niveau je
commence en tant que loisir mais
pourquoi pas et on en arrive à parler
voilà de championnats du monde de
déplacement un peu partout c'est ça ça a
pris vite une ampleur assez importante
même des fois ça m'a un peu surpris à me
dire bah ça va assez vite et de voir
tout ce qui est prévu la règle de voir
par exemple sur la fin de l'année de me
dire j'ai encore tout ça à faire mais
c'est ça aussi qui est motivant puis ça
c'est aussi un une aventure qui se fait
avec avec mes parents aussi et mes
frères et soeurs qui me suivent et toute
l'équipe qui a derrière quoi et c'est ça
qui est qui est jolie il y a de
l'engouement et
Eric d'ailleurs en termes d'engouement
comment vous êtes soutenu vautours et
qu'en pense vos proches de ce que des
défis que vous relevez alors les
justement donc mes proches mes enfants
par exemple qui m'ont qui m'ont
encouragé et qui en parle beaucoup
autour d'eux notamment dans leurs écoles
et tout ça donc c'était c'est comme ça
que j'ai commencé à faire mes
interventions d'ailleurs sur la région
mes proches me soutiennent et mais ils
ont bien compris que je faisais ça aussi
pour eux pour leur montrer que
l'handicap n'était pas un frein quoi que
on pouvait dépasser ce blocage et je
fais ça après il est possible pour eux
pour leur montrer voilà je qui est tout
est possible à partir du moment où on
essaie de se donner les moyens
alors on peut faire toutes les choses
peut-être différemment mais c'est la
finalité qui compte et donc ouais je
suis vraiment très soutenu par mes
enfants par mes parents
c'est encourageant effectivement comme
message sans doute de montrer que non
seulement on peut faire des choses mais
des choses sympathiques et rencontrer du
monde et vivre voilà des expériences
découvrir des paysages ça peut être
motivant quand même moi ça me motive en
tout cas
de ce projet de ces défis personnels il
y a aussi l'aspect de d'offrir un peu
par le biais de mon association que j'ai
créé à des familles à des enfants en
situation de handicap une activité un
peu extraordinaire et donc il y a aussi
cette finalité au final je sais que
l'année prochaine au printemps
j'emmènerai au minimum 4 faire un vol en
montgolfière adapté donc voilà et
comment s'appelle votre association pour
ceux qui nous regardent pour eux je
pour eux et donc vous collectez
des fonds pour pouvoir faire vivre des
expériences un peu extraordinaires à des
enfants c'est ça c'est ça voilà donc là
la première activité qui va être offerte
ça va être donc un vol en montgolfière
adapté au fauteuil roulant et donc c'est
offert aux enfants et à leur famille
donc oui encore une fois ça génère
beaucoup de rencontres et de un peu
d'événements à potentiel
c'est fabuleux je sais pas ce que tu en
penses Clémence sur le côté fédérateur
du sport est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que tu retrouves effectivement sur les
déplacements l'ambiance la fraternité
peut-être ou voilà ou d'autres choses
oui c'est ça exactement c'est nous dans
l'équipe de France quand on parle à
l'étranger c'est vraiment on se on se
soude tous et c'est ça qui est vraiment
beau et ça se ressent aussi énormément
lorsqu'on est amené à faire des épreuves
par équipe parce que oui donc en escrime
on a aussi des épreuves individuelles
mais du par équipe et c'est à ce moment
là où voilà en forme qu'un et quand on
va on est tous les uns derrière les
autres et c'est ça que je trouve que je
trouve jolie oui il faut vraiment une
dimension collective en fait c'est ça et
c'est ce qui te plaît toi aussi dans
dans les screams exactement c'est que
c'est un côté individuel et qu'on
retrouve aussi ce côté collectif où on
est tous ensemble qui est qui est sympa
c'est vrai qu'il y a une forte dimension
aussi solidaire et y compris là en
portant effectivement des sujets autour
du handisport est-ce que avant de
pratiquer les scribes ou même pendant
l'athlétisme peut-être ou dans d'autres
domaines tu avais un petit peu envie de
t'emparer du sujet du handisport et
d'aller le faire connaître
vraiment c'est ma première expérience en
handisport du coup c'était l'athlétisme
et j'étais qu'avec des valides étaient
indisport mais j'étais la seule la seule
Andy et donc c'était une approche un peu
différente là vraiment avoir mis
vraiment les pieds dans un club
handisport mais en étant pas la seule
Landi j'ai trouvé ça vraiment enfin
c'est ça représente un autre aspect
parce qu'on est vraiment il y a plus de
monde donc on est plus là à partager et
c'est vrai que quand on voit qu'on est
peu nombreuses aussi en handisport c'est
vrai que c'est aussi le moment où on
peut on peut montrer aussi c'est quoi
notre discipline et
plus de mon dossier avec nous ce serait
top parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est dur de
trouver des inscrits c'est ça et de
faire connaître un peu les clubs donc on
n'est pas très nombreuses même chez les
garçons ils sont pas très nombreux mais
encore moins chez les filles et donc du
coup c'est vrai que si ça gagnerait en
visibilité c'est en train de gagner en
visibilité notamment avec les jeux de
paris 2024 où il y a le plus en plus
c'est vraiment plus mis en avant mais
c'est sûr que si s'il y avait plus de
monde même pour nous ce serait aussi top
mais c'est vrai qu'à l'approche des Jeux
effectivement ça va permettre de
communiquer encore plus c'est sur
différentes disciplines sportives c'est
ça exactement oui tout à fait et
Eric de même est-ce que vous aviez des
interrogations peut-être sur le
handisport ou ou des envies de de porter
un peu plus certaines disciplines alors
jusqu'à l'année dernière l'handisport
c'était vraiment quelque chose d'inconnu
pour moi et suite à mon premier voyage
en vélo j'ai décidé de trouver un sport
justement
on va dire un peu plus collectif ou je
rencontrais du monde parce que tout seul
sur son vélo c'est c'est bien mais bon
on se remet beaucoup en question et on
n'a pas beaucoup de réponses par moments
et donc je me suis mis au tennis de
table on dit sport et donc j'entame ma
deuxième saison et donc je serai
certainement pas sportif de haut niveau
comme Clémence mais j'ai des ambitions
j'ai des ambitions d'essayer de pouvoir
justement essayer de jouer au moins une
expérience en internationale et c'est
vrai que depuis que j'ai voilà j'ai
intégré un club handisport je
m'intéresse beaucoup plus à l'handisport
et
et j'ai envie de tout essayer et de
découvrir et d'en parler sans arrêt quoi
un peu donc dans cette logique c'est ce
que vous vous m'aviez dit avant
l'émission dans cette logique de
toujours plus avec toujours l'envie de
découvrir et de se lancer un peu des
nouveaux défis c'est ce qui vous
caractérise aussi je crois oui c'est ça
voilà tout à fait et de dans cette même
logique sur vos périples donc le dernier
était de 1500 km c'est ça les 340 134
oui je rebondis là-dessus parce que ça
peut quand même impressionner comment on
encaisse ce nombre de kilomètres et
comment on encaisse y compris quand on
peut avoir des douleurs ou une situation
particulière
alors on prend déjà beaucoup soin de soi
ça veut dire qu'à chaque étape voilà des
massages et autres
beaucoup de repos
la préparation mentale j'en parlais tout
à l'heure mais la préparation mentale
est vraiment très importante c'est ce
qui m'a permis de pouvoir tenir
et face aux difficultés on a toujours
les choses qui nous motivent
aller à la rencontre des autres la
sensibilisation
l'association et c'est comme ça que j'ai
réussi à aller jusqu'au bout
on arrive très bien tôt à la fin du
temps règlementaire de la rencontre donc
un petit mot peut-être pour finir je
reste pour l'instant avec vos Eric un
petit message à passer aux gens
peut-être pour qu'il vienne vous
rencontrer sur les étapes ou qu'ils
puissent vous soutenir alors je tiens à
jour une page Facebook qui s'appelle je
roule pour lutter contre ma maladie mais
pas que donc ça veut tout dire voilà je
fais du vélo mais pas que du vélo et de
plein d'autres choses
faut pas hésiter à prendre contact
il y a d'autres projets qui sont qui
vont être mises en place dans les mois
années à venir et j'espère que ça va
continuer pendant très longtemps c'est
tout ce qu'on vous souhaite et on espère
que les gens vont suivre a pas de presse
sur vos réseaux sociaux et Clémence de
ton côté est-ce que tu veux ajouter
quelque chose sur l'escrime ou motivé un
peu les gens pour qu'ils puissent venir
découvrir
leur dire que faut pas hésiter à faire
la démarche d'aller dans les handisport
parce que c'est on est vraiment bien
suivi puis c'est vraiment adapté et
qu'il y a de plus en plus de sport en
handisport qui sont proposés et que
c'est une expérience formidable et bien
sûr cette expérience formidable merci
beaucoup pour ces derniers mots merci à
tous les deux d'être venu dans ce sujet
pour le meilleur et pour le sport merci
pour vos témoignages
Eric et Clémence merci à vous d'avoir
suivi ce très très beau sujet j'espère
qu'il vous aura motivé autant que moi et
on se retrouve à très bientôt bien sûr
avec les yeux de Morgane
[Musique]